[inaudible].
Any of you have asked us for a video
explaining what communism is all about,
so well paired is if you have been
following this channel for a while,
you'll probably know that when not
exactly on the communist side of the
spectrum,
but before having an opinion about
something.
It's important to be informed about
this.
Plus,
at the end of this video,
we're going to share some takeaways
about mocks that just might surprise
you.
The Internet is full of trolls who will
either sing marks his praises or hate on
him without ever having read it.
[inaudible]
it's why people ends up in leaving quite
a lot of stereotypes about communism
that's simply on true.
Now,
before I saw it,
I will say that this is a summary of
Friedrich Engels and column boxes ideas
on communism only.
We've only got 10 minutes,
so it's going to be impossible to cover
authors who came after or the politics
of the Soviet Union.
But with that out of the way,
let's get started.
The first thing
you need to know that may surprise you
is that mark's was eight materialist of
thinker.
That means that he thinks the main
driver of social change is material
goods.
The foundation of Marxism is to
determine which goods have more value
than other goods,
but it do be warns here that we are
talking about value,
not a balanced price.
Price can be influenced by other things
such as taxes or monopolies.
For Marx,
the value with the good is measured by
the work needed to manufacture it.
So for an example,
how much is a chair with it would be the
sum of the carbons does working hours
who put the chat together as well as the
some of the working hours of the
lumberjack.
You cut down the tree as well as the
some of the working hours of the
blacksmith who made the nails that went
into the chair and this goes on man's
almonds on in summary,
it's all the work of all the people who
went in to making it as the chair.
Don't forget this because it's very
important in understanding the idea of
capitalist exploitation and though this
has nothing to do with working hours or
worker's condition
[inaudible]
it's the wealthier is this some under
mocks?
The welfare is the sum of all these
people's work,
right,
but these people,
they only get a share of the wealth of
that they create.
The rest is profit for the factories.
This one
needs that.
If these people are working eight hours
a day,
they're only getting a fraction of that.
Maybe the first three or four hours
work.
The other part,
the part that the businessmen receives
is cold substance.
Bye.
Their produce
value.
He's there for the exact expression of
the expectation,
the glory of the working force by the
Capitol or the worker by the capitalist.
So something you might be wondering how
is it possible the business owner to
exploit the workers so easily?
Why on the workers getting the whole
value that they're generating?
The answer is because they don't have
the tools required to take the raw
materials and turn them into a finished
product,
a factory,
a workshop,
whatever.
This is Marty.
An economic jargon is called the means
of production or capital means.
In fact,
this is why the person who owns these
things is often called a capitalist.
Now,
despite what some people think marks has
no problem.
If you want to own a fancy car or a
really expensive mobile phone,
he just has a problem.
If you want to own the means of
production,
this means having a company.
But why is this a problem?
Well,
let's take a look.
[inaudible]
[inaudible] of capitalism
now mocks divide society into two
classes.
On the one hand you have the
capitalists,
the bourgeoisie,
and on the other hand you have the one
that gives the pro to terry at the
bourgeoisie own the production process
and they exploit the workers.
The workers are the ones who were doing
the work and making the value,
but they only get the bread crumbs from
the bourgeoisie.
Therefore,
we have a confrontation or why you might
have heard of a class struggle,
and this is what Marx defines as the
original sin of a market economy.
And as you can clearly see,
it has nothing to do with poverty or
inequality.
In fact,
in Nordic countries where the difference
between the wealthy and the poor is not
so great,
there is still capitalist exploitation
as long as the means of production is in
private hands.
This is why [inaudible] doesn't just
focus.
His criticism was on capitalists,
but also on Social Democrat
[inaudible]
that'd be less systematic,
but yet more practical of socialism
dries to freeze any revolutionary wheel
from the working class.
Claiming it is not a political reform
that will give them benefit,
but only the modification of their
material life conditions.
In summary,
the working relations of capitalism are
based on one group living off another
group.
This is what Marx calls the
infrastructure of capitalism.
Nevertheless,
in order to make this work,
the bourgeoisie,
you need some sort of secret weapon to
keep that supremacy.
That's why they create a government.
They create laws,
they create even religion.
This is what Marx calls at the
superstructure,
also known as a cultural hegemony.
So what is Marxists solution to end all
of this injustice?
Girls Revolution.
Further Marx believes that capitalism is
unsuspecting
[inaudible]
claim that their goals can be only
achieved by the violin over throat of
every existence,
social order.
In fact,
he even predicts that the first
countries to fall will be the biggest
industrial nations specific green.
He predicts the fall of the United
Kingdom,
which was the leading industrial nation
of Islam,
right?
He's 14 their own destruction and their
own undertaker.
The proletariat
boss here is the most ironic part of the
story.
If you look at all the facts,
the countries that have had marxists
revolutions are things that never had an
industrial revolution and never had a
bourgeoisie.
These are countries like Russia or
China,
which never had a capitalist system,
at least how mark's defined it,
those countries with advanced
capitalism,
it never even had a revolution.
Maybe the only exceptions would be
Hungary and Czechoslovakia,
but these were cases where communism
didn't come through a revolution,
but by the USA army invading those
[inaudible]
key question,
the boxes.
Philosophers wonder during the 20th
century is where is the revolution?
The marks promised us.
This is a question that many people have
tried to answer to philosophers that I
would specifically recommend reading on
this topic are yoga and the harbor mass
and then turn to your grand scheme.
They looked at human language as well as
how humans perceive reality to see why
we haven't had this revolution.
Interestingly,
this research has even been useful in
possibly the least boxes thing you can
imagine.
[inaudible]
that is definitely something we are not
going to address in this video,
but we'll save it for a future video.
If you're interested in learning how box
relates to marketing,
do let us know in the comments below.
If you are interested in finding out
more about this topic now,
then you can check out a book written on
the subjects,
but unfortunately it's only in Spanish,
but it is written by one of the hosts of
the Spanish visual politic channel.
Send your funds sacker but as I said,
it's definitely something we'll consider
addressing in a future video.
[inaudible]
shed our opinion with you,
but what do you think of Marx's
theories?
Do you think that they're still relevant
in the world we live in today?
Let us know in the comments below.
We'd love to read them and hear your
thoughts and don't forget that we upload
brand new videos every Monday and every
Thursday say,
don't forget to subscribe.
Click the button on the screen or the Lo
Mein.
Now,
if you liked this video,
do give us a thumbs up.
It lets us know that we are doing a good
job and I'll see you next.